[Music]
how many of you have found yourself in a
situation where you're talking to
someone from another country from
another culture or from another state or
city that you don't quite get what
they're saying you're just kind of
confused cameras rings and it kind of
cool it at sometimes you just you don't
know what's going on well we're here to
talk to you today about cross-cultural
communication and we think it's a very
important topic to the four of us and we
hope it's valuable to you as well
so first thing we want to show you is
cross culture exchanges everywhere and
if some put up a little bit funny
picture there but it shows you that even
simple things like a market you know
remote place in China that is doing this
as well but so the point here is did you
know that translation service is
actually 40 billion dollar industry and
it's going 8% a year did you know that
40% of your classmates here from another
country did you know that also tourism
and cross-border Commerce and all the
things required you want to cultural
understanding that sometimes actually
you know beyond the simple language and
what I was showing here is a picture of
a George W with King Abdullah from Saudi
you might find that strange but it's
actually in their customs to hold hands
with two men thought it just goes to
show that it is really a powerful aspect
of communication that all this cultural
difference is underlying what we say so
the thing we also want to point out is
we haven't had a session on
cross-cultural communication from this
class so I think it's underappreciated
in some sense and sometimes you know we
all speak English here obviously at the
GSB but it will utilize some of the
underlying differences that people don't
really express from a purely linguistic
perspective and the second the last
point and the second last point is we
need some of these things are very hard
to know because we are talking to
someone from another culture little bit
really give you a lot of feedback or
when you lose attention on them they
don't really you know give you hey sorry
I didn't understand that fear really
happens on it you know you guys are
really close so but the good news for
for all of you guys is we're here to
help so today was
talk to you guys about some of our
personal stories from the past what we
experience and hopefully bring to you
what JD turn you know conscious
incompetence so you're aware at least
100 someone from another culture that
are some things are not going across and
lastly we're going to offer you some
advice and tips so you guys have a sense
of you know what maybe small things you
can do to be very effective so with that
I'm not passed on to some Jawas going to
talk to you about some of the vertical
communication challenges yes so what we
want you to take away from this class is
to stay lick you want you to listen
inquire and test things out whenever
you're talking to people who are from
different cultures but before we even do
that what are some things that might get
into the way of that well in Fred dance
book an introduction to intercultural
communication there are three things
that we consider to be barriers to
communication when it comes to the
aspect of listening
the first one is anxiety I mean how many
of us have travelled the world has got
into a new country we're like we're not
really sure what the norms are we're not
really sure what the culture is or how
to shake hands or do other things
anxiety is a number one reason that
people are impacted and it affects
people's communication across cultures a
second one is judging other groups by
your own culture aeverine this may seem
common sense but you might think that
everyone does the same things or asking
maybe you do when you go into a new
environment and that's another reason
why people have found it really
challenging to communicate with people
in other cultures a third reason is the
same language different meanings means
Jeff speaks English icing English after
the other cohort speaks English but I'm
speaking Nigerian / American English
decreasing British English and after
speaking Australian English we're all
speaking the same language but there are
different words that means different
things and it's important to be very
aware that these we might be using the
same words but to understand that there
might be deeper meaning in those words
and so to bring it back to the GSB what
are some common mishaps that happened I
mean how many of us have been in a class
where someone has said something go
ahead and break a leg I remember the
first time I came to us and someone told
me to do that I was really concerned and
backed away slowly but that's not what
that means then encourage them maybe
or about to go on a show but these are
their Expedia Matic expressions such as
this that if you're coming from another
country you may not be very familiar
with what that means and it's important
to recognize that that you may have to
explain that to another person another
expression is references a professor in
class ask someone a question to which no
one answered and she proceeded to say
Bueller Bueller Bueller who knows what
I'm talking about this is a reference to
Ferris Bueller's Day Off now in a class
like this where the class is 40%
international you may not know what that
means and you've lost 40 percent of your
class and they are lost they've missed
the entire message of what you're trying
to get across
we're very guilty of this especially at
the GSB and it's very important to be
aware that when you make movie or TV or
even sports references then not
everyone's going to understand what
you're referring to the third one are
non-existent words and what I mean by
that is if you're if for example you're
speaking Spanish they're the word that's
used in Spanish but there's not trend it
doesn't the word is not exist in English
there's a very difficult to transfer
from one language to the other and if
you find a word that's very close some
of that meaning is also lost so being
very aware what that means so that's it
for verbal communication remember to
stay late I'll pass it on to Ola so when
I was five years old my family moved
from the u.s. to Mexico
we made wonderful Mexican friends there
they taught us local customs traditions
and then gestures as well some of these
gestures included thank you
and mucho which is also kind of a lot or
kelsa mean it's crowded here so then
about a year and a half later we picked
up and moved to Argentina and this is a
picture of very famous place in
Argentina it's also one of the worst
intersections you can imagine for
traffic there's blames me effectively
nothing direction of travel is kind of a
suggestion and one day my father was
driving my brother and I along this road
and by some weird fluke some guys
stopped to let us merge in front of
father was confused for grateful and
gestures what he believed to be kind of
thank you a lot and is also proud
you think this is like the perfectly
efficient you suggest and like from one
second to the next
this guy goes from this calm relaxed guy
letting us in front of him to this kind
of maniacal road-raging monkey man who
jumps out of turn trip like beating on
the hood in the windows of our car so at
this point I'm really thankful that when
my father steps out of the car his
physical stature alone is enough to kind
of resolve this issue but later that
night we learned that two chilean of
whom there are many in argentina
the mexican mucho is actually launched a
which is frequently used as Conchetta
zoom oddity or directly translated as
your mother's shell so i will let you
all think about the detail there but
this was an example of a dangerous
assumption you don't want to make about
nonverbal communication so well it can
be an extremely effective and useful
tool I urge you all to be both aware and
respectful of not only the obvious
differences in kind of personal space or
gestures alike it's not that I wish my
father or eye contact but also have a
more subtle and nuanced differences in
the cultural understanding of time and
of the pace of activity and the use of
silence and also use of touch so that's
when the turned over church thank you
will and that wasn't Mexican thank you
not as suggestion about Williams mother
I'm sure is a wonderful lady and anyone
in here ever used a translator has
anyone it's a very interesting and
challenging experience i I was in the
military and I served in Middle East and
then in Southeast Asia a lot of the
partners that we work with to mentor and
conduct their own missions didn't speak
English they either spoke a language of
Afghanistan or Tagalog which is a
language and southeastern Philippines so
I often found myself feeling with
translators and so the tools that I'm
going to share with you today
things that I learned the hard way
through a lot of sweat and tears and
embarrassment one of those that I'd like
to highlight is that humor doesn't
translate nearly as well and through
another language particularly through
the filter translator if you can imagine
the downside of really offending someone
in another language is huge and trying
to get a small chuckle out of someone
isn't even worth the risk my advice to
you don't try and make a joke through a
translator something that I am very
guilty of is that when I would have
meetings I would speak to my translator
and I would lose rapport with the
audience that I was actually trying to
free to so it maintained a conversation
and eye contact with one individual as
the issue was meant to translate to the
audience and I completely isolated and
marginalized this person because I
focused on the translator so I'd
encourage you if you're ever using a
translator in fact just be mindful to
maintain rapport and body language and
eye contact with your intended audience
not your translator something that to me
seems intuitive as I look back and
having made these mistakes is something
about preparation sit down and present
with your translator or share your
slides with your translator prior to the
actual event so that they can proofread
and help you out and actually own you
own your own message something that's
unique about translators is that you
think you have your own microphone but
what the audience actually hears is the
translators message not your own so if
you're going to own your message make
sure that you craft it exactly how you
want it in practice with your translator
there's a number of other things that I
have stories I would share with you but
we're running out of time
one of those is around jargon and
colloquial phrases I think we've we've
learned a lot about that this morning
through Willems gestures as well as the
sports metaphors but I just want to
reiterate it don't try and make a
colloquial phrase with through a
translator because it just isn't going
to work well and so when it comes to
translators and then wrapping it up what
we really want you guys to take away is
this cute little acronym we devised to
stay lit really do listen enquire and
test anytime you're going to be
communicating cross culturally and
lastly we want to serve as
sources for all of you going forward so
I've listed our contact information
behind us and some of the geographies
that we've exposed ourselves to so if
you ever find yourself either throughout
your career at the GSD or after Business
School going to one of these geographies
drop us a note and we can give you some
of the stories and lessons that we learn
the hard way so that you don't make the
same mistakes that we did
[Music]